we are back now here at 7 30 on CBS
mornings and marking one year since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine an invasion
that continues to send shock waves all
around the world just today the U.S
announced new sanctions against Moscow
and in a visit to Ukraine on Monday
President Biden promised that the U.S
will support and continue that support
will not Tire until Russia withdraws or
is defeated Russian President Vladimir
Putin also talking about all this blamed
what he called American aggression for
the conflict and he has suspended
Russia's participation in the last
remaining nuclear arms treaty with the
U.S to talk about all of it we've got
Secretary of State Anthony blinking with
us Mr secretary good morning to you
thank you very much for being here uh
these are issues you know uh not just
for years but for decades you've been
involved in National Security multiple
administrations from what you know and
what you see right in this moment is
there a way this conflict ends in
Ukraine without America getting more
involved
I think we have to sustain our
involvement and that's what we're
determined to do but not just us dozens
of countries around the world Tony we
were here in New York a year and a week
ago warning the world about the
impending Russian invasion
now a year later Ukraine is still
standing it's still free it's still
independent Putin's first objective was
to erase it from the map to absorb it
into Russia that has failed and that
will fail the main reason is incredible
courage of the Ukrainian people but also
the support that dozens of countries
around the world are provided and are
determined to continue to provide yeah
well support goes in multiple directions
and on the subject of warnings we're
also hearing from the Intel community
that China is considering lethal Aid to
Russia in support of their effort How
concerned are you with that and what
sanctions are on the table for
preventing it so we are concerned and in
fact that's one of the reasons that I
made it public last week what we've seen
from day one is if you go back to before
The Invasion started just a couple of
weeks before that Vladimir Putin and
president Xi Jinping of China had a
meeting and they said they had a
partnership with no limits we were
concerned from day one that that
partnership might result in China
providing lethal military assistance to
Russia for use in Ukraine and so we've
said from day one don't do it we have
information recently that they're now
thinking about doing it and so we tried
publicly uh to as well as privately to
warn them against it there is no point
in adding fuel to the fire China's
trying to have it both ways they're
trying to present themselves as neutral
and a party for peace while at the same
time aiding and abetting Russia's war
effort what sanctions are on the table
to prevent them from providing this Aid
well there are a multiplicity of
possible sanctions I don't want to get
into the details but what we've said to
them very directly including in a
meeting I had with their senior foreign
policy official in Munich last week is
that this would be a serious problem in
our relationship
there's trying times in America for
people financially and oftentimes we
might sit back and hear about what's
happening in Ukraine and hear about the
money that U.S is pouring into Ukraine
and the resources that we're pouring
into Ukraine why are we doing that for
those that are watching and asking that
same question so first uh taxpayers have
been incredibly generous and we have to
make sure that we're using their money
wisely in Ukraine two things first I
think viscerally most Americans don't
like to see a big country bullying
another and they just feel it's wrong
and want to do something about it but
fundamentally what's going on is this
after two World Wars the world came
together uh and started the United
Nations and the objective was to prevent
another world war and countries around
the world agreed on some basic rules
some basic principles like one country
just can't attack its neighbor can't try
to seize its land by force can't try to
erase it from the map can't bully it
that's exactly what Russia is doing so
it's aggression against Ukraine isn't
just an aggression against the people of
Ukraine yeah it's an aggression against
those very principles that are at the
heart of maintaining peace and
disability so if you let that go
unchecked Pandora's Box open of course
there's everywhere come out we're living
in a world of confidence Michelle real
quick this is the second part of my
question as I'm talking about resources
that we are pouring in we're providing
weapons as well and forgive me if this
is a question that should be
self-understood but does that mean that
um that puts us in a position of a
disadvantage do we have enough weapons
for ourself to protect and serve this
country David Martin reported just last
night that we have low stockpiles and
some key areas and if there were a
conflict we'd run out of for example air
to ship missiles very quickly so I can
tell you that the Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin chairman of the Joint
Chiefs Mark really are extremely
Vigilant about making sure that whatever
happens we always have what we need to
defend ourselves uh wherever it's
wherever it's needed okay at the same
time of course
these weapons have had a real effect on
Russia's military Russia's got about 80
percent of its Ground Forces committed
to Ukraine they are taking terrible
losses terrible losses in in Personnel
Public Accounts two hundred thousand
killed or wounded and then their own
tanks their own Weaponry is being
destroyed by the ukrainians back to your
point about the New World Order where
are we I mean we we came out of two
world wars uh we we had a cold war are
we back where we started Russia now
announced that that it's suspending
participation in the singular remaining
nuclear pact with the U.S so I'm mean
are we back to a state that we were in
with the Soviet Union so I don't think
so and here's why just yesterday again
in New York U.N General Assembly 141
countries well over two-thirds of the
countries at the United Nations again
stood up and voted against the Russian
aggression spoke out against it for
peace uh condemning what Russia was
doing uh that's the third time that's
happened over the course of this war
more than 140 countries standing up to
do that so I don't think we're looking
at the world dividing into rigid
ideological blocks the way we saw during
the Cold War at the same time you're
exactly right shall the Russians pulling
out suspending their participation this
Arms Control deeply irresponsible even
during the Cold War we had Arms Control
agreements we have a responsibility to
do everything we can to reduce the role
of nuclear weapons we're serious about
that responsibility Russia is not how
what is the U.S opinion at this point of
Vladimir Putin he clearly is an
aggressor is he somebody acting
rationally is he somebody who you can
imagine will pull out or seek peace in
this year ahead
you know Tony one of the challenges we
have is not always applying our frame of
rationality to someone else from our
perspective he hasn't been because
everything that he's done has been to
precipitate what he says he wants to
prevent uh Ukraine more united more
divided hates the Russians for
Generations NATO the West more united
not divided we have two new members that
will soon join NATO so that doesn't seem
rational on the other hand if you look
at what he said over the years he's
obsessed with eliminating Ukraine as an
independent country absorbing it into
Russia it's forming a new Russian Empire
in that frame I suppose there's a logic
to it but what we know is this it's
failing yeah it's failing it's a brutal
logic as well secretary Anthony blinken
thank you very much for being here
appreciate it appreciate you